all right here's a whole new meaning to  the term extra guac  chipotle is using recycled avocado pits  to  dye t-shirts other apparel and  accessories because it's all part of a  new clothing line from chipotle  chipotle goods available for purchase  by the company's 15 million rewards  members  profits go towards sustainable fashion  and farming chipotle says it's  left with 300 million avocado pits  each year so that's what they do they  take the avocado pits they don't need  anymore and  make clothes out of them guys i think  alex that could be a new trend  using unused food clothes like  everything else  we thought of that month ago i know